We met in that coffee shop.
You remember?
I looked at you and I liked you from the beginning.
You wanted me to think that you were lost, so you asked me for directions...
...and we ended up talking all night.
I never forgot that summer.
We dated for four years.
We saw each other constantly although we lived in two different countries.
It was hard, but we didn't care.
Finally, we decided to get married,...
...and although it was tough, I moved to your country.
We had two kids, six grandchildren.
Huh! Six!
Can you believe it?
We grew old together.
You gave me a life full of happiness.
That's why it's so hard to let you go...
...because I lost you the moment I decided not to take that trip...
...nor to come to this city, to that coffee shop.
I lost you when I canceled my trip.
I lost you because I never met you.